adani's financial crisis is threatening
to become a political one Friday session
of parliament was adjourned within 10
minutes as opposition parties continue
to raise the issue the governing BJP is
distancing itself from the adani
controversy
the government has nothing to do with it
there's no connection
the opposition is accusing the BJP of
favoring adani for lucrative
infrastructure contracts they say the
company's founder Gotham adani is close
friends with prime minister Narendra
Modi
as you know the government is resisting
they don't want these issues to be
discussed they didn't want China to be
discussed in the last session they don't
want unemployment and prices we
discussed any issue that the government
thinks will embarrass them they don't
want to discuss it economists say
political pressure May Force the
government to get involved if the
opposition raises the issue seriously in
the on the streets then I think
Mr Modi if they don't do that then Mr
Modi could escape and they would work
out a strategy of how to delay the
inquiries how to drag on the affair for
some time and they say not there's
nothing
opposition parties are demanding a
Judicial inquiry and a debate in
Parliament
opposition parties say they're concerned
about the impact on public money a
government-run insurance company has
invested billions of dollars in adani
companies and India's largest public
bank has given the group a two and a
half billion dollar loan the government
says the exposure is too low to cause
concern
the National Stock Exchange has limited
trading activity for samadhani companies
in the U.S the Dow is removing one adani
group member from some of its indices
opposition parties say they will
continue to demand answers and are
planning a nationwide protest next week
Al Jazeera New Delhi